مؤمن ما الذي سجل من تطورات في الساعات
الماضيه في جنوب
القطاع نعم جلال القصف والغارات
الاسرائيليه ما زالت متواصله حتى هذه
اللحظه وتحديدا القصف المدفعي على مختلف
المناطق في مدينه خانيونس وتحديدا المناطق
الغربيه المحيطه بمجمع ناصر الطبي وايضا
بمستشفى الامل التابع لجمعيه الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني حصيله الشهداء خلال هذا
ال ومن تمكن المواطنون من ايصال جثامين
الشهداء او حتى العدد المحدود من سيارات
الاسعاف الى مجمع ناصر الطبي على وجه
التحديد ارتفع الى 20 شهيدا واكثر من 100
مصاب وصلوا الى مجمع ناصر الطبي بالاضافه
الى ثلاثه من الشهداء وصلوا الى المشفى
الاوروبي الى الجنوب الشرقي من المدينه
الاشتباكات العنيفه تدور راها في المنطقه
الغربيه من مدينه خانيونس وهي المنطقه
التي توغلت اليها دبابات واليات جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وحيث حاصرت عدد من
الاحياء السكنيه بالاضافه الى مراكز
الاواء سواء التابعه للامم المتحده الانرو
او المؤسسات الحكوميه من جامعات ومؤسسات
اخرى جيش الاحتلال طلب من جميع النازحين
من الاف النازحين في مراكز الاواء بضروره
اخلائها في هذه المنطقه على وجه التحديد
حتى ساعات فجر هذا اليوم لان انه سيوسع من
نطاق عملياته العسكريه حسب الدعائ ما دفع
بالالاف في هذه الاجواء البارده وتحت
المطر الى النزوح باتجاه منطقه البحر
متوجهين الى مدينه رفح هنا او الى مدينه
دير البلح في وسط القطاع من ضمن الحالات
الصعبه التي حدثت هذا اليوم في مدينه خان
يونس هو طلب جيش الاحتلال من سكان حي
الامل باخلاء المنطقه دفع عائله بربخ على
وجه التحديد طفل لم يتجاوز الث عش من عمره
رافعا الرايه البيضاء ليجتاز الشارع امام
منزله فعجله قناص اسرائيلي بعيال ناري في
صدره وراسه فجاء اخيه الاكبر لانقاذه
وانتشال جثماني فعاجله هو الاخر ليرتقي
الشقيقان شهيدين برصاص قناص اسرائيلي حتى
اوامر الاخلاء التي يطلب جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من السكان المدينه او حتى من
النازحين فانها تكون تحت نيران قناصه جيش
الاحتلال وايضا المدفعيه الاسرائيليه يوم
امس ارتقى على الاقل 14 شهيدا في مقر
الصناعه التابع للنور حيث اضطر النازحون
لدفن هؤلاء الشهداء جميعا داخل مبنى مقر
الصناعه الى في غرب مدينه خان يونس وايضا
من تبقى اجبروا على النزوح واعتقل جيش
الاحتلال عدد من الشبان والرجال الى
واقتاده الى اماكن مجهوله دون ان يعرف
مصيرهم حتى حى هذه اللحظه